when you first look at biomutin in
action there's a sense that it's a
mashup of different fantasy and science
fiction genres
all vying for control described as a
post-apocalyptic kung fu
fable the action storytelling on display
presents an adventure that's an
intriguing mix
of the classic animated film secret of
nim along with the platforming and
action games like enslaved odyssey to
the west and
devil may cry and therein lies the hook
for by mutant
it wears its weirdness on its sleeve
presenting an alluring take on what the
post-apocalyptic earth
would look like once the animals inherit
the world before its full release on may
25th we had the chance to check out a
final preview of biomutant
we got a clearer sense of the game's
focus on action and storytelling and how
the hero's journey will evolve in a
world full of talking animals
and decaying automatons stories only
survive if someone is listening
so pay attention first revealed back in
2017
biomutant is the debut game from
experiment 101
a studio made up of the former
developers from the just core series
biomutant is a departure that instead
focuses on more exploring a
zelda-like map with action-rpg mechanics
that blend third-person combat and
rpg-like progression
while you may play as a nameless
protagonist biomutant's story is told
from the perspective of a narrator
who feels lifted from a children's
animated film however this works in
biomutant's favor
it presents a charming if unusual take
on a post-apocalyptic action rpg
where your narrative decisions and
tactics in combat are given commentary
from an omnipotent observer
this area is bio-contaminated
it's really hazardous the main plot
focuses on the hero's quest to save the
tree of life from rival clans
and an evil group known as the world
eaters who seek to trigger
a new apocalypse just before the intro
you can customize your hero's breed and
class types
along with their height fur colour and
some surprisingly robust options for
body proportions
define your genetic structure one of the
more intriguing details in biomutant is
its surprisingly robust crafting system
like its story in combat the crafting
element leans heavily into the
scavenging aspect of surviving
in the post-human world and all the
trinkets and scrap you find when
exploring the world
can be repurposed into new guns and
melee weapons one example we saw during
our preview was a new melee weapon
crafted from a walking cane
a pair of scissors and a mangled metal
safe door resulting in the kane
stronk box you can also add special
elemental modifiers to the mix
turning your jury rigged weapons into
death dealing machines
like the legend of zelda biomutant
features a mix of open exploration and
fast-paced
target locked combat when exploring the
different zones the hero character will
be able to leap
dash and rush across the large
landscapes and explore buildings to
scrounge supplies
and unearth clues about the planet's
ancient history on top of that they will
also be able to ride mounts made of
scrap
to explore the most dangerous areas of
the world including a toxic waterway
and heavily irradiated zones that
require you to constantly monitor your
health
we saw the broad strokes of what the
world is like during our look at the
game
and it's an incredibly detailed and
vibrant setting to see
however it still left me wondering about
the density of the game's apparently
eight by eight kilometer world
and how interconnected its locales will
all be in the final release
which was unfortunately difficult to get
a sense of in our preview
now the world is quite dangerous but the
hero character of biomutant comes with
an assortment of skills and weapons
to meet each challenge head on just like
in capcom's devil may cry your tactics
in combat focus on mixing melee strikes
with your firearms and special magic
attacks
which open up some clever opportunities
to hit enemies when they're most
vulnerable
but can sometimes come off as a bit
disorientating with a sudden shift
between third person and
lock-on targeting the number of options
you have can present some fun and
thrilling opportunities to finish a
fight in style
biomutant is balancing various mechanics
and approaches to storytelling
which certainly make for an enticing
take on a post-apocalyptic adventure
game this new open world
game has been a long time coming and
with its full release coming on may 25th
we're poised to see how this
post-apocalyptic kung fu fable
will unfold for more on biomutant and
other games releasing this summer
make sure to hit that subscribe button
and of course check on gamespot.com
[Music]
you